gosh I got to start with the physical
transformation we're the same age 47 I'm
trying to get rid of five pounds around
my belly you put on 50 looks like you
got rid of it nicely how did you do so
yeah how do I get rid of it
how did you put on how'd you get well
putting it on was easier and fun
nice burgers beer whenever I want to be
taking it off and I get ready and I did
attend a fast just to kickstart my body
into going oh we're going with without
for a while anything dad just said
choose fast but that kick started and
then it was just you know your body
wants to go your body has a mean weight
it has a weight it wants to live at so
once you get it started wants to go back
there
whether you're gaining or losing I think
okay I'm trying that starting today no
more eggs and bacon for breakfast no
it's not the breakfast you violent
breakfast yeah don't eat don't eat your
dinner after 6:30 if you're trying to
lose I do that I do that you eat after
6:30 no I keep it before so you trying
to lose five pounds yeah just right here
around here just that spot I got a pass
banks renting town what else what else
what else driving it like sit-ups
push-ups obviously all that good weight
doing that you know lose weight doing
that well you tighten up your tone hmm
okay
the cardio you lose you've quite an era
of course wasn't sit-ups of course okay
enough about that let's get if I may
please you were let's I want to talk
about what your son told you I think he
said that I want you to play another
role like Kenny wells he said you were
so much fun can you elaborate on that
conversation where he did my son didn't
say that specifically the whole family
just you know I was my nicknames captain
fund while we were shooting gold because
we have her much her little I brought
Kenny home I was a lot of fun as Kenny
is so much fun right so I was much more
of a yes man mm-hmm
you know to late night going bowling or
to the car or having pizza on Tuesday
morning and it was pretty much yes -
great I did
kids love that family loves that yeah
yeah I noticed similarities between
Kenny as a prospector his drive his
passion to yours as an actor your drive
your passion your commitment didn't you
see that along the way
um I admire the obsession that Kenny
Wells as the full-blown commitment to
chasing down his dream that he has is
inspiring to me the fact that he
followed a literal dream that he had and
bought a one-way ticket you know get it
is pretty powerful stuff guys got a real
purity of spirit yeah and he means well
he's a hard liver mm-hmm he lives hard
you got nine lives and he's uh he's
thrown five Hail Marys in his life and
caught all five of them he's he create
archetype that way so he's inspiring guy
that have as far as his resilience and
belief